We take so much for granted...
...like going to school, watching TV, seeing a movie, keeping you warm at night.
It's easy to forget that every day,...
...millions of people living in poverty are fighting for their lives.
Progress is being made.
Tens of millions more kids in school.
Millions more people on lifesaving AIDS medicine...
...and malaria deaths cut in half in countries all across Africa,...
...but more needs to be done.
This is not about charity, it's about justice.
It's about equality.
Over the course of history, young people, people like us have made a difference.
We have changed laws.
We have broken barriers.
We have decided elections.
We can defeat extreme poverty and preventable disease...
...by all working together across borders, time zones, and cultures...
...through awareness, advocacy, and action.
As college students, you have the power.
You have the power to build a better future.
Create a buzz.
The more people talk, the more we can accomplish.
You and me, all of us, coming together as one.
One.
As one.
Join us.
Go to One.org.